JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking about Taylor
series and different sorts
of manipulations you
can do with them,
and different examples
of Taylor series.
So I have an example
here that I don't
think you've seen in lecture.
So this is the Taylor
series 1 plus 2x plus 3 x
squared plus 4 x cubed plus
5 x to the fourth, and so on.
I'm going to tell you that this
is a Taylor series for a fairly
nice function.
And what I'd like you to
do, is try and figure out
what that function is.
Now, I'm kind of sending
you off onto this task
without giving
you much guidance,
so let me give you a
little bit of a hint, which
is that the thing
to do here, is you
have a bunch of different
tools that you know how
to manipulate Taylor series by.
So you know how to, you know,
do calculus on Taylor series,
you can take derivatives
and integrals,
you know how to add and
multiply and perform
these sorts of manipulations.
So you might think
of a manipulation
you could perform on this
Taylor series that'll
make it a simpler expression,
or something you're already
familiar with, or so on.
So let me give you some
time to work on that.
Think about it for a while.
Try and come up with the
expression for this Taylor
series.
And come back, and we
can work on it together.
So hopefully you had some
luck working on this problem,
and figured out what the
right manipulation to use is.
I didn't-- I kind of tossed
it at you without a whole lot
of guidance, and I don't think
you've done a lot of examples
like this before.
So it's a little tricky.
So what I suggested was
that you think about things
that you know how to do that
could be used to simplify this.
So looking at it, it's
just one Taylor series.
So it's not clear that sort
of Taylor series arithmetic
is going to help you very much.
It's not obviously
a substitution
of some value into some
other Taylor series
that you're familiar with.
It's not obviously, say,
a sum of two Taylor series
that you already know very well.
So those things don't,
aren't immediately,
it's not clear where
to go with them.
One thing that does
pop out-- well, OK.
So let's talk about some of the
other tools that I mentioned.
We have calculus
on Taylor series.
So we have differentiation.
And if you take-- so we see
here that the coefficients are
sort of a linear polynomial.
If you take a derivative,
what happens is,
well, this becomes
2 plus 6x plus 12x
squared plus 20x cubed.
And those coefficients,
2, 6, 12, 20, those
are given by a
quadratic polynomial.
So that makes our life kind
of more complicated, somehow.
But if we look at this, we see
that integrating this power
series is really easy to do.
This power series has a
really nice antiderivative.
So what I'm going
to do, is I'm going
to call this power series
by the name f of x.
And then what I'd
like you to notice,
is that the
antiderivative of f of x
dx-- well, we can integrate
power series termwise.
And so what we get is--
well, so all right.
So I'm going to do--
I'm going to put
the constant of
integration first.
So the antiderivative of
this is c plus-- well, 1,
you take its integral
and you get x.
And 2x, you take its
integral, and you just
get plus x squared.
And 3 x squared, you
take its integral
and you get plus x
cubed, and plus x
to the fourth from the next
one, and plus x to the fifth,
and so on.
So, OK.
So I put the c here, right?
So any power series of this
form is an antiderivative
of the power series
that we started with.
Any power series of this
form has the derivative equal
to thing that we're
interested in.
And since we really
care about what f is,
and not what its
antiderivative is,
we can choose c to be
any convenient value.
So I'm gonna, in
particular, look
at the power series
where c is equal to 1.
And why am I going
to make that choice?
Well, because we've
seen a power series
that looks very much like
this before, with the 1 there.
So we know 1 plus x plus
x squared plus x cubed
plus x to the fourth and so on.
We know that this is
equal to 1 over 1 minus x.
OK?
So since we know that
this is the case,
that means that our
power series, f of x,
is just the derivative of this.
That's what we just showed here.
So, f of x is equal
to d over dx of 1
over-- whoops that should
be 1 over 1 minus x.
OK?
And notice that,
you know, if I'd
chosen a different
choice of constant here,
it would be killed off
by this differentiation.
So it really was irrelevant.
So d over dx of
1 over 1 minus x.
Yes, of d over dx of 1 minus x.
And, OK.
Well, this is an easy
derivative to compute.
This is 1 minus
x to the minus 1,
so you do a little
chain rule thing,
and I think what you get
out is that this is 1 over 1
minus x squared.
So this gives me a nice formula
for this function f of x.
If you wanted to check,
one thing you could do,
is you could set about
computing a few terms, the power
series for this function,
for 1 over 1 minus x squared,
1 over 1 minus x quantity
squared I should say.
So you could do that either by
using your derivative formula,
which is easy enough to do.
Another thing you
could do, is you
could realize that this is 1
over 1 minus x times 1 over 1
minus x, so you
could try multiplying
that polynomial by itself and
that power series by itself,
and see if it's easy to get
back this formula that we had.
But any of those
ways is a good way
to double check
that this is really
true, that this function, that
this power series here, f of x,
has this functional form.
Now of course, I
haven't said anything
about the radius of
convergence, but the thing
to remember when you're doing
calculus on power series,
is that when you take a
derivative or an antiderivative
of a power series,
you don't change
the radius of convergence.
Sometimes you can fiddle with
what happens at the endpoints,
but the radius of
convergence stays the same.
So this is going
to be true whenever
x is between negative 1 and 1.
And in fact, this series
diverges at this endpoint.
That's pretty easy to check.
So there we go.
So this is the functional
form for this power series.
It's valid whenever x is
between negative 1 and 1.
That's its range of convergence.
And so here we have a cute
little trick for figuring out
some forms of power series.
And of course if you were
interested, so like I said,
now you had a-- you could look
at the derivative of this,
which I mentioned had some
coefficients that were given
by some quadratic polynomial.
Now that you have a functional
form, you could figure out,
you know, "Oh what,
you know, what
is the function
whose power series
has that quadratic
polynomial as coefficients?"
And you can do a whole
bunch of other stuff
by similarly taking derivatives
of other power series
that you're familiar
with, or integrals.
So I'll stop there.